↘︎です。今まで数々のYouTuberの捕獲に
成功してきた実績がある私であれば→
もうそのYouTuberさんが例えば→
複数人でも→
捕らえる方法があると思うんですよね
今まではHIKAKINさんを捕まえ→
そしてSEIKINさんを捕まえ→
MasuoTVをエロ本で釣り→
YouTuberはそれぞれ特徴があるんで→
その特徴さえしっかり掴めば→
大人数とか多数とか
グループだとしても→
きっと！
捕まえることができると思います
というわけで　今回捕まえるYouTuberは
コチラ！
水溜りボンドのお2人です
よろしくお願いいたします〜　どうも〜
今日も元気にやっていきましょう〜
やー　そう　ムズいんですよ
2人組といってもやっぱ→
カンタとトミーは両方
性格が違うんで→
多分　生物学上的に→
2人を同じもので
釣ることは不可能なので→
その両個体を別々のものと考え→
各生物に見合ったもので
釣ることができれば！→
この2つの生物両方を→
家に確保することができる
のではないかなと思っております
今回　結構　難易度高めの→
YouTuber捕獲作戦になると
思うんですけども。
まぁ上手くいくかどうか
わかりませんが→
ちょっとやってみようと思います
ではいこう★
はい　というわけで
じゃあまずはトミーですね
トミーという生物を
捕獲していきましょう
私　トミーという生き物とは
付き合いが長くてですね
あいつは性格上
大食い　食いしん坊なんで↗︎
なので今回　5人前のピザを
準備させていただきました
この大量のピザをもってすれば
あの水溜りボンドのトミーは…
ピザを見た瞬間　あいつは多分→
居ても立っても居られなくなる
生き物なので→
はじめさんの家とか関係なく→
上がってくること
間違いないと思います→
では準備していきましょう★
はい　というわけで
ピザを設置していきます
捕まえるところまでピザをとりあえず
置きまくっていきます
…ッシャァ
仕掛けていきます
♪〜
こっちから来ると…
釣られて…
♪〜
そして階段を上ると…
最後に…
ハァ…ハァ…ハァ…
あ　つ　い
早速　トミーが捕獲できるかどうか
見ていきましょう★
♪〜
すいません　いただきま〜す
…いただきま〜す
♪〜
[チャイム音]
あっ　お邪魔しまーす
あれっ　ピザある
えっピザあるの？
ピザあるもん…なぁ…
♪〜
お邪魔しまーす！
あ　上？
♪〜
お邪魔しまーす　上がりまーす
や　ピザ！
や　ピザ…
や　ピザ〜　ピザじゃ〜ん…
わかんない　この動画の正かｉ…
わぁ穴空いてるし
ピザかと思ったわ　その穴がピｚ
ピザがあるな…
♪〜
どこのピザ？
それでは！
ピザを食べていきたいと思いま〜す！
あ　美味しそう！
だああああああああああ
確保おおおおおおおおおお！！！！
いやもう
途中式がわからなすぎるぅ！
どういう動画なんスか！
(はじめ)こういうの〜
(トミー)え　なんスか？
貴様は食べ物が大好きらしいな〜ｗ
(トミー)はい！
(はじめ)ピザを準備したら→
簡単にホイホイ付いてきおって！ｗ
(はじめ)はいというわけでみなさん
ご覧いただけましたか
無事！水溜り…ボンドの片方…
トミーを確保することができました
いやもう完全に策に飲まれましたねぇ
もう気づいたらはじめさんの家…
入っちゃってたからね
(はじめ)おー　やっぱ　そーかぁー
(トミー)そうなんスよ
やっぱ誰にしても
好きなものがあるんですけども
(トミー)そうなんスよね
(はじめ)だからぼく水溜りボンドを→
捕まえようとするとき
トミーとカンタは別の生き物なんで→
(トミー)たしかに。
(はじめ)カンタはちょっとピザだと→
確保できないんですよ
そこで私　準備しました！
(トミー)なんですか？
(はじめ)カンタを捕獲するもの…
コチラです！
♪〜
フｗ
(はじめ)これです！
いや兄さん…ｗ
(はじめ)どうですか？　(トミー)いやぁ…
エッチなお姉さんの本じゃないスか…
(はじめ)カンタはこれなんですよ多分。
私の予想だと。
これ…をぼくのピザシステムで→
置いとくってことですか？
(はじめ)そうです。
カンタはぁ
マスオさんと同じで→
逆の存在であるものを見たときに
不思議な衝動に駆られて→
ついつい　付いて行ってしまう…
まぁなんか彼が気づいてない
この〜…
内なる欲望ってことですよね？
はい。真反対に存在するものだと
思うんで　これ。カンタの。
(トミー)そうですねたしかに
きっと　この初めて見る　エロ本に！
ｗｗｗ
アイツ　エロ本初めて見るんですか？
避けてきたと思うんスよ！
や〜　たしかに　ちょっとそこの道
通らないようにしてる…気はしますね
早速　カンタを捕獲…してい…ければ
いいなと思います
(トミー)よろしくお願いしまーす！
(はじめ)はい！
♪〜
ｗｗｗ
あ〜…
♪〜
ｗｗ
でもスゴイし…スゴイな
よくこんな集めたな
いやスゴイな
こっちってことですよね？
大丈ｂ…モザイクですよこれ。
♪〜
あぁ〜
フフッｗｗ
♪〜
や　置いてあるじゃないすかｗ
確保おおおおおおお！！！！
(カンタ)イタイ　イタイｗｗ
[通常ED]
(カンタ)ヤバいってぇ〜↑
なにしてんスかぁ〜！
まんまと引っかかったなカンタァ〜
(カンタ)いやいやいやｗｗ
(はじめ)ごめんなんかちょっと苦手そう
だったから申し訳ないなと思いつつも…
いやいやいや全然全然…
うれしいです。
ｗｗｗ
(はじめ)うれしい…ｗ
(カンタ)うれしいですじゃない
いや　はじめさん家に
はじめて来たのが！
(はじめ)あぁ　なるほどね？ｗｗ
(カンタ)うれしい…うれしいですよ？